gilbert bejjani bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
derrière ces chiffres inquiétants bien
sûr plusieurs facteurs un politique
statistiques géographiques
selon vous comment expliquer ce très
grand nombre de décès par million
d'habitants la semaine passée je disais
que c'était le la façon de comptabiliser
et en effet c'est le cas toujours
puisque des patients qui décèdent
on ne sait pas toujours ce qu'il était
positif donc depuis une semaine l'état
des pistes massivement les personnes
âgées qui résident dans les ehpad et on
se rend compte en fait de ils sont je
dirais pas tellement positif 10 9%
essentiellement des patients qui sont
symptomatiques et donc quand on ne tient
pas compte du type ps spécifique du
décès en avons pas des statistiques qui
sont différents des autres pays
c'était en cours je dirais
d'harmonisation avec des règles qui vont
être redéfinis et corrigé c'est à dire
que c'est une méthode de comptage plus
large finalement que dans les autres
pays que pour laquelle la belgique
adopté finalement tout à fait vous donne
quelques précisions
quand on regarde l'amour tapis la
mortalité habituel dans un pays ce qu'on
appelle la mortalité attendue et en
belgique en général ça fluctue avec les
saisons donc plus de morts en hiver
qu'en été
mais la moyenne 10 ans est de 330 par
jour et donc il faut attendre quand même
qu un mois complet soit passé pour voir
quelle est la mortalité qui a été au
delà de ce qui était attendu
quand on regarde le mois de mars en tout
cas pour le mois de mars la mortalité
qui est qui qui qui est au delà de ce
qui est attendu
elle était en belgique comme celle de la
hollande
aux alentours de aux alentours disons
d'une centaine de cas par million
d'habitants ce kit est nettement
inférieur à l'ile-de-france et à l'est
de la france
c'est vrai qu'au début avril la première
semaine d'avril on dépasse ce ce chiffre
et on est plutôt aux alentours de 150
on est légèrement au dessus de la
roulant mais on est dans la moyenne des
chiffres qui étaient ceux de
l'ile-de-france et de l'est de la france
il faudra certainement attendre la fin
du mois d'avril pour pouvoir regarder ce
nouvel indicateur qui est donc la
mortalité excédentaires par rapport à ce
qui est habituellement attendu dans un
pays tenant compte bien sûr de la
pyramide des âges de la comorbidité etc
quel regard est ce que vous portez sur
la stratégie du gouvernement en belgique
est ce que il ya eu un manque
d'anticipation dans le cailly selon vous
j'ai souvent défendu le point de vue
qu'il n'y a pas eu de manque
d'anticipation il ya eu rarement en
matériel il ya eu un manque en dépistage
mais pas en anticipation et d'ailleurs
on voit très bien actuellement que le
nombre d'admissions aux hôpitaux est
inférieur au nombre de sorties des
hôpitaux
autrement dit la courbe
d'hospitalisation qui était déjà stable
commence à diminuer le nombre de
patients qui sont en soins intensifs et
qui sont ventilés au respirateur est
également en train de diminuer
autrement dit la l'épidémie est sous
contrôle
c'est vrai que comme je le répète que
entre le 11 et le 15 avril il ya eu
quelques pointes de mortalité
supplémentaires qui ont été
comptabilisés qui ont fait bondir le
chiffre national de décès mais je pense
qu'il faudra attendre la fin du mois
pour pouvoir ré analyser ces chiffres en
tout cas l'épidémie se stabilise et
encore hier le gouvernement a rappelé
que la prise en charge des patients dans
les hôpitaux va rester essentiellement
axée sur le coup vite donc on ne lâche
pas on ne lâche pas les mesures qui sont
prises de haut niveau des hôpitaux pour
la prise en charge des patients pour
conclure la question du déconfinement ou
est-ce qu'on en ait un
gic un léger déconfinement donc certains
types de magasins à vont pouvoir ouvrir
pas encore les écoles puisque le
confinement reste d'actualité jusqu'au
début mais également c'est la même chose
pour les hôpitaux les hôpitaux ne
peuvent pas reprendre une activité
normale et reste on va dire prêt pour la
prise en charge du co vite les mesures
de distanciation sociales sont toujours
d'application et donc à part l'ouverture
de certains magasins en respectant
certaines petites feintes certaines
règles de précaution habituelle
il n'y a pas encore de déconfinement en
belgique
merci beaucoup gilbert bejjani d'avoir
répondu à une question j'appelle que
vous êtes anesthésiste réanimateur